sur le parv les files d'attente sont de
plus en plus longues pendant de jours le
vélodrome de 50 ans Eveline a ouvert ses
portes au grand public et un seul mot
vient à la bouche des visiteurs c'est
vrai que c'est très très impressionnant
toute la voûte qu'il a audessus avec
tout l'esèce de rail je sais pas ce que
c'est mais c'est une construction qui
est très impressionnante oui à peine
entré dans l'enceinte les curieux
aperçoivent la piste olympique et la
plupart s'attarde à contempler cet outil
unique au monde en tribune c'est très
aéré che nous vraiment je pense qu'on a
un point de vue magnifique sur la piste
et l'air centrale n'importe où on se
trouve dans l'installation donc c'est
très très bien belle réalisation des
gradins au centre de la piste il ne
fallait descendre que quelques marches
pour se retrouver exceptionnellement sur
l'air centrale zone habituelle de
l'échauffement des professionnels
l'occasion d'approcher l'équipement
spécifique nécessaire pour la piste on
en a un mais pour la route il y a des
freins il y a tout ça celui-là il est un
peu plus léger hein alle il y a le
minimum strict minimum ah c'est
magnifique ça doit pas ça doit pas êre
donné ça c'est très beau ça fait envie
d'en
faire si cette opération permet de faire
découvrir le Centre national du cyclisme
elle pourrait faire naître quelques
vocations la piste est est une
discipline assez méconnue parce qu'il y
a très peu de Vélodrome encore moins de
ce calibre là puisque on peut considérer
que le site est vraiment unique donc
voilà c'est forcément quelque chose qu'
démocratiser et puis qu'il faut
expliquer aux gens du territoire qui
sont pas tous des cyclistes voilà ce
weekend 12000 personnes ont pu découvrir
le
Vélodrome